IS A MEDICAL >> Greg: BASH THE M
IS A MEDICAL >> Greg: BASH THE D
IS A MEDICAL >> Greg: BASH THE A
IS A MEDICAL >> Greg: BASH THE E
IS A MEDICAL >> Greg: BASH THE Y
CHANCE I CAN.
HERE GOES.
AFTER THE EL PASO SHOOTING, 26%
JUMP IN HATE CRIMES LINKED TO
TRUMP RALLIES.
IT WENT EVERYWHERE.
THANK     THEY ALSO ANALYZED THE
THANK     THEY ALSO ANALYZED THF
THANK     THEY ALSO ANALYZED THC
THANK     THEY ALSO ANALYZED THT
THAT HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN
RALLY.
THEY FOUND THAT HER RALLY LED TO
AN EVEN GREATER INCREASE IN HATE
RALLIES THAN TRUMP RALLIES.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SCIENCE
MARRIES THE MEDIA.
THE   POLITICAL RALLIES ARE USUL
THE   POLITICAL RALLIES ARE USUY
HELD NEAR LARGE POPULATIONS
WHERE CRIME IS HIGHER.
THERE WERE ALSO A FEW INCIDENTS
OF HATE CRIMES, UNLIKE SMALLER
TOWNS WITHOUT RALLIES, WHO
REPORTED NO SUCH CRIMES.
QUITE EASILY, REASON SHOWS THAT
YOU COULD SEE THE SAME WITH
HILLARY RALLIES.
HOW COULD THE MEDIA FALL FOR
THIS QUESTION A WHILE, THEY
WANTED TO FALL FOR THAT.
THEY SELL JUNK TO PEOPLE WHO
NEED TO BELIEVE THE SAME THING
THEY BELIEVE.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD REPORT THAT
CRIME, SINCE THAT BUSINESS MODEL
SEEMS CLOSER TO A FELONY THAN IT
DOES TO JOURNALISM.
YOU KNOW, DANA, I HATE THIS
MAGAZINE.
WHILE, I APPLIED FOR A JOB THERE
IN 1989 AND I DIDN'T GET IT.
>> Dana: WHO WAS THE CULPRIT?
>> Greg: WELL, THE EDITOR WAS,
I THINK VICTORIA.
BUT THEY DO STORIES LIKE THIS,
ALMOST WEEKLY, FOR THE PAST 40
YEARS.
>> Dana: I BET THEY ARE GOING
TO DO ONE ON CALIFORNIA
EMISSIONS.
NO, I'M SAYING THAT THEY WOULD
EXPLAIN IT TO PEOPLE SO THEY
DON'T GO AROUND SAYING OH, WOW.
CALIFORNIA IS SO MUCH BETTER
THAN EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Greg: THEY ARE DOING WORK
ON VAPING.
THEY ALWAYS TAKE THE OTHER SIDE
THAT PEOPLE ARE REPORTING ON,
AND IN THIS CASE, THEY FOUND NO
DETECTABLE IMPACTS, JESSE, FROM
THE RALLY.
THEY JUST SHOWED THAT IT WAS ALL
JUNK.
>> Jesse: I AM SO GLAD THAT
YOU ARE DOING THIS STORY.
[LAUGHTER]
ONE IS THAT, PROFESSORS AREN'T
REALLY THAT SMART.
PEOPLE HOLD THEM IN HIGH ESTEEM,
AND YEAH, SOME OF THEM ARE DOING
GROUNDBREAKING WORK.
BUT A LOT OF THEM --
>> Juan: I THINK YOUR SISTER'S
ON THE PHONE.
>> Jesse: YEAH, SHE'S
EXCEPTIONAL.
IN THIS CASE, THEY ARE NOT EVEN
THAT BOOK SMART.
LET'S JUST CHECK OURSELVES AND
PUSH A LOT OF FAKE NEWS.
LOOK HOW EASY IT IS FOR FAKE
NEWS TO GO MAINSTREAM.
THEY TOOK AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WRITE THIS AS A LEGIT ARTICLE
AND THEN EVERYBODY READS IT AND
IT GETS ON CABLE TV, AND THEN
POLITICIANS START TALKING ABOUT
IT.
HOW MANY SCIENCE STUDIES HAVE
THEY DONE ON GLOBAL WARMING, ON
GUNS, ON RUSSIA.
THINK ABOUT ALL THE OTHER FAKE
THINGS THAT HAVE GOTTEN
MAINSTREAM THAT A SIMPLE
FACT-CHECK PROVE THEM WRONG.
AND THEN LASTLY, CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA IS BASICALLY SAVING THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE DOING GOD'S WORK.
THEY ARE FACT-CHECK IN
"NEW YORK TIMES," CNN.
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY POKING
HOLES.
IT'S EXHAUSTING.
>> Juan: YET.
>> Jesse: 75% OF CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA ARE REBUTTING THE LIES BY
DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: IT IS NOT A
CONSERVATIVE MAGAZINE.
IT'S LIBERTARIAN.
THEY HOLD TRUMP TO THE FIRE MORE
THAN ANYBODY, BUT THEY ALSO ARE
SO GOOD AT READING STUFF THAT
THE OTHER JOURNALISTS DON'T REA
READ.
>> Juan: I'M ALL FOR THEM.
I LIKE THAT KIND OF JOURNALISM.
I THINK THEY DEBUNK MYTHS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
I'M LISTENING TO JESSE, AND I
THINK WOW.
I THINK JESSE SEES IT AS SOMEHOW
CONFIRMING HIS PERSPECTIVE.
NOT DEBUNKING ANYTHING.
IT'S IN A DEBUNK THE IDEA THAT
HATE CRIME REALLY HAS STRUCK IN
THE COUNTRY.
[LAUGHTER]
BETWEEN 2016-2017, 17% DROP IN
HATE CRIMES, 37% ON A TAX ON
JEWISH PEOPLE.
IT'S THE ONE I DON'T THINK YOU
WANT TO CHASE THAT NUMBER.
>> Emily: JUST FROM A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BACKGROUND, IT WAS THE
MOST DISTURBING THING.
THE FACT THAT PUBLIC PERCEPTION
MATTERS.
IT MATTERS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT MATTERS FOR SAFETY.
IT MATTERS FOR THE VICTIMS.
THAT HAD A REAL EFFECT.
THE SAD PART TO ME IS THAT WE
ARE THE ONLY ONES KIND OF
PUTTING FORTH THE CORRECTION.
>> Dana: THANKFULLY, WE ARE
THE MOST-WATCHED SHOW.
>> Jesse: IT WAS RETWEETED BY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
>> Greg: I'LL NEVER FORGET
THAT.